ça va pas non il y a pas qu'il y a
quelqu'un ah non je l'ai pas vu monsieur
passer chez moi c'est chez vous ah bon
je ne savais pas
voyez pas là c'est écrit là il y a écrit
l'autre il y a rien écrit
et ben oui mais je suis désolé mais il y
a rien écrit là regardez il y a rien
écrit
[Musique]
pourquoi vous m'envoyez des bouteilles
dans la gueule
des bouteilles vides j'en ai pris une
sur la tête oui c'est normal
ah de merde
[Musique]
ou quoi quoi
vous mettez les bouteilles là-dedans
j'appelle prendre
deux bouteilles 4 francs depuis quand
depuis cette semaine c'est pour
sensibiliser les gens à mettre le
bouteilles en verre dans le container
toute la journée en plus j'ai très soif
et les gens ils mettent que des
bouteilles vides dites dedans
[Musique]